[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
feld und meine lieben freunde ihr seht
ja wir befinden uns hier immer noch in
dem schnee und wir haben ja hier in der
letzten folge unser bettchen
aufgeschlagen außerdem wird
selbstverständlich direkt wieder mit und
werden uns jetzt hier irgendwo
untergraben denn in der letzten episode
haben wir auch die ende augen hier
hingeschmissen und hier drüber ist ein
händler auge zerplatzt und das heißt ja
dass ich hier unten auf jeden fall dass
stronghold befindet also der
höhenbereich der uns zum end portal
bringt und das portal bringt uns ja dann
zum ende von minecraft weil du kommt
hier vorne mithin balu bis zu reggae
wallufer richtet hier vorne unter dem
baum jetzt sein geschäft bis zufällig
dass wir keine antwort auf meine frage
ok perfekt blues reggae das heißt meine
lieben freunde wir bauen und sich
einfach mal runter ich nehme da kann man
den schnee weg und dass sie wird der
bereich sein wo wir uns runter bauen die
sache ist jetzt sicher in der letzten
folge gefragt habe ob er einige tipps
für mich habt und wollte mir zuallererst
erst mal das hier geschrieben
wie machen wir das jetzt endlich mit
blumen
ja weil ich nicht will dass du da unten
draufgeht von daher meine lieben freunde
ich hab ich grad schon eingeblendet mir
wurde halt in die kommentare geschrieben
man soll sich nie direkt runter bauen
sondern nur so treppen weise deswegen
bei euch jetzt einfach mal zwei blöcke
immer nebeneinander ab dh wenn ein blog
irgendwie wegfallen sollte und wir uns
eventuell in eine schlucht rheingraben
dann würden wir eine menge fall schaden
bekommen was viele allerdings auch nicht
verstanden und episode war dass ich
natürlich jetzt noch nicht ins ende gehe
sondern erstmal nur schauen wild was
dort unten überhaupt abgeht dass wir in
der letzten folge kann nicht lange zeit
verlieren werden sondern direkt hier
hinfahren werden das gewissen
es geht schon los
meine lieben freunde
ich höre auch lava
und wir sind auch schon extrem tief
man sie toben
er keine ahnung was man oben sieht
es seit der himmel allerdings graben wir
uns gehen
[Musik]
wir haben das ende gefunden freunde ich
nehme einfach mal mein lover und machte
die lava ein bisschen weg so dass wir
uns hier entspannt darüber abbauen
können ihn natürlich ein paar fackeln
dran platzieren und hier die koppel
stones auch wieder weg damit wir hier
her laufen können meine lieben freunde
was ich gerade sagen wollte war dass
einige in der letzten folge dachten dass
ich in dieser folge jetzt schon ins
entgehe das ist natürlich nicht der fall
ich möchte nur erstmal schauen dass wir
hier überhaupt vernünftig hinkommen und
uns auch einen weg schon mal da hin
bauen so dass wir nicht in der letzten
episode erstmal noch voll viel zu
kämpfen haben mit irgendwelchen monstern
und so weiter und so fort bevor wir uns
jetzt durch diese wand hierdurch bauen
und uns in der stronghold rein bewegen
werde ich zunächst erstmal ein crafting
mensch nehmen und mein holz und mir hier
vorne einen weg hoch bauen im sinne von
leitern und wir sind auch jetzt schon
oben angekommen ist ist jetzt natürlich
ein bisschen doof weil wir hier so ein
zweiter weg kamen allerdings werde ich
jetzt einfach eine art blog hinsetzen so
dass wir ganz entspannt herunter gehen
können die sonne ist am mittag
angekommen ich werde mir jetzt einfach
mal hier lassen ich habe ein bisschen
schiss wenn monster kommen und so weiter
und so fort aber ich denke mal dass er
das schaffen wird beziehungsweise kann
ich ihn ja auch so ein bisschen einbauen
also ich werde bald einfach mal eine
provisorische hundehütte kurz bauen oder
dass er hier auf jeden fall keine
probleme bekommen wird also ball bleibt
auf jeden fall hier wir gehen runter und
schauen uns jetzt mal hier unten die
höhle an bzw generell dass stronghold
ich setze man ein paar fakten nennen
dass auch das hier schön ausgeleuchtet
ist hier wird zwar nicht spawnen
allerdings schauen wir uns das ganze
jetzt mal an meine workbench nehme ich
mit meine lieben moment man nun
eben momente
meiner lieben freunde der moment ist
gekommen ich baue den ersten block ab
kann das direkt der eingang seien zum
nada portal
[Musik]
das wurde mir auch in die kommentare
geschrieben ich sollte keine blöcke
abbauen da dort ja diese silberfische
spawnen können die sache ist allerdings
das fliegende auge
ballaballa
[Musik]
berlin
liebe
leute 2 max hier
es war ja auch schon wieder klar dass
das rollt nicht einfachen stronghold ist
sondern dass es direkt an eine höhle
angrenzt ich werde jetzt einfach mal die
namen wege also alles das wo monster
herkommen können ausleuchten wird die
kohle hier lassen wir sind nicht hier
heute für ärzte sondern wir sind hier
wirklich damit wir uns einen entspannten
fortschritt schaffen können und
entspannt in folge 100 hier reingehen
können allerdings ist dass sie wirklich
eine riesige höhle also ich leuchte die
gänge jetzt einfach mal nur so ein
bisschen aus wenn ja vorhin schon dahin
gelaufen und hier hin dass auf jeden
fall alles geregelt allerdings geht es
hier natürlich auch noch war mein gott
alter an ihr seht allerdings direkt auch
schon die strukturen das heißt das dass
hier auch zum stronghold gehört das
heißt dass stronghold befindet sich ein
bisschen in der höhle drin ich muss mich
auf jeden fall auch noch ein paar neue
fackeln mache nicht jemand der seite
rotwein wächst hier
da unten sind drei keeper
da werde ich jetzt definitiv nicht
hingehen meine liebe freunde wir
konzentrieren uns auf das traumhaus ich
werde allerdings auch nicht im
vornherein gehen sondern ich werde von
der seite reingehen wo ich vorhin auch
ankam die allerdings erst mal noch ein
paar verkehr hinsetzen ich habe keine
mehr
jetzt muss ich doch ein bisschen kohle
abbauen gefordert habe ich jetzt gerade
mal eine riesige kohle abgebaut ihr seht
ihr unten rechts im inventar das 46 pole
h wird + ich habe mir auch schon 60
fakten gemacht von daher können wir
jetzt diese ganze kohle hier erstmal
lassen hier unten habe ich gerade auch
noch kohle abgebaut und wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt wohin bereits
gesagt ich auf diesen bereiche vom
stronghold sondern laufen zurück nach
dorthin wo wir hergekommen sind sind ja
vorhin hier rechts aus der wand
rausgekommen plötzlich erstmal eine
fackel drüber damit wir wissen hier
geht's auf jeden fall nach oben und
jetzt schauen wir uns mal das ganze ein
bisschen weiter an hier geht's auf jeden
fall nicht weiter hier war nur die höhle
und hier vorne rum können wir gehen ich
glaube allerdings dass wir hier aber
okay das ist hier der durchgang gewesen
und hier unten waren die ganzen krieg
also haben wir hier auf jeden fall keine
weitere ecke wo wird lang laufen können
hier sind wir vorhin hergekommen das
heißt hier befindet sich nur noch im
durchgang hier waren wir gerade und hier
können wir durch den hier ist alles
dunkel
hier geht es runter da schaue ich gleich
mal lang erstmal hoffe ich fühle mich
ein bisschen wie base länder man damals
und das von ihnen deiner seite wenn ich
mich umdrehe dass du dein instrument
kommt dabei wir gehen jetzt mal einfach
hier die werden die treppe runter
ganz langsam gesiegt bin sehr froh
darüber dass e mail geschrieben habt
hier geht es nicht weiter perfekte kam
das heißt es geht generell in diesem
ganzen bereich hier nicht weiter und von
daher können wir theoretisch sagen dass
das hier für uns komplett uninteressant
ist deswegen werde ich jetzt einfach mal
meine bruchsteine nehmen und hier vorne
das ganze zu bauen so dass wir wissen da
müssen wir nicht lange ich gehe jetzt
mal hier runter und hier geht's auch
nicht lang
obwohl die mich verarschen
wo geht es denn jetzt weiter
doch jetzt nicht ich muss da runter
gehen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob ich ihn drücken soll
den schaltern
[Musik]
aber wir haben keine andere wahl
ich glaube ich muss das machen
[Musik]
irgendwo hier öffnet sich eine tür
macsteel
[Musik]
ich bin
verängstigt
[Musik]
wir befinden uns inmitten einer riesigen
schlucht
gegenüber wartet ein fr wir haben hier
unten dachte ich gerade dass da auch
noch keeper wer
ist aber nicht ich muss mich allerdings
weg nicht rüber bauen damit ich dort
auch hinkomme ich werde den jetzt
einfach
[Musik]
ja oder wir machen es halt einfach so
ich muss ja auf jeden fall ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz ganz vorsichtig vorgehen
um hier auf jeden fall schon mal ein weg
geschaffen den werde ich jetzt auch
einfach mal hier an der seite ein
bisschen absichern dass wir hier nicht
runterfallen werden die erfahrungspunkte
die für ihn runter gefallen sind sind
wir eigentlich relativ egal auch die
ganzen ärzte ich die da oben erde
eingeblendet das heißt wir sind auf
jeden fall nicht weit unter der erde und
da stellt euch mal vor ich hätte mich
dort runter gebauten wir werden hier
runter gefallen das hat auf jeden fall
nicht gut geendet ich werde auch hier
kurzen ein ganz kleines geländer eben
bauen so dass wir hier entspannt lang
laufen können und genau das gleiche
werde ich auch hier in dem bereich
machen wir werden auf jeden fall ein
bisschen länger hier verbringen meine
lieben freunde bin sehr sehr sehr sehr
froh war den kommentar dass ich das
ganze bitte nicht in der letzten folge
machen soll die werden nämlich unendlich
lang geworden wahrscheinlich das was ich
auch einfach mal hier stehen dann wissen
wir dass wir hier um auf jeden fall
zurück nach hause müssen wir können dann
hier vorne einfach lang ich habe
wirklich keine leute
[Musik]
ich habe keine lust mich hier noch zu
verlaufen
wollte ich sagen und dann kommt auf
einmal ein prima von oben runter
gefallen
freunde wir dürfen glaube ich gar nicht
lange zeit vergehen ich darf ihnen gar
nicht lang mich irgendwie umschauen wir
sind angekommen wir sind schon da wir
sind schon da leute jetzt das portal
jetzt
das portal wir sind schon da oh mein
gott jetzt erstmal ganz gut von weiteren
kommentaren mir wurde geschrieben sollte
diesen spor japan das ist nämlich der
silberfisch borner und dann haben wir
auf jeden fall keine bösen erwachen
erfahrungen wenn wir rauskommen dass
irgendwelche silber verschieden und uns
irgendwo in die lava schubsen unter dem
portal ist aber meine lieben freund und
ihr seht ja auch ich habe im excel fände
augen gemacht denn wir haben hier 3 6 9
12 steckplätze für die ende augen wir
haben schon ein paar steckplätze gefühlt
haben auf jeden fall glück gehabt und
können jetzt in die restlichen die ende
augen reinsetzen und dementsprechend das
portal
[Musik]
wenn ich hier rein gehe
bin ich am ende
und man kommt aus dem ende nicht wieder
raus
außer man stirbt
oder man besiegt hat diesen fetten
drachen aber
schauen wir dann ob ich das hinkriege ob
die sache ist auf jeden fall dass ich
diese lager hier jetzt erstmal weg
machen muss weil ich keine lust habe
dass ich die da irgendwie rein falle und
zudem muss sich auch noch
selbstverständlich dass hier vorne weg
machen und auch die lava hier vorne kurz
weg machen jetzt ist alles zwar ein
bisschen dunkel wir leuchten das
allerdings natürlich selbstverständlich
alles aus so dass hier keine monsters
born werden und irgendwer und gegen wie
ein strich durch die rechnung macht von
daher haben wir das jetzt auch
ausgeleuchtet das bett was sich mit
genommen habe werde ich jetzt schon hier
neben setzen so dass ich beim nächsten
mal nicht vergessen werde und dann
irgendwie wenig spawnen oder sterben
sollte oder keine ahnung was das ich
dann irgendwo wieder zu hause geboren
und lebe ich erstmal zehn jahre hier hin
bewegen muss also wir haben die
vorbereitungen mehr oder weniger
getroffen wir haben das end portal
gefunden meine lieben freunde und das
war das ziel für die heutige episode ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass es sich
tatsächlich direkt hier vorne befindet
noch mal ganz kurz zur erinnerung dort
vorne sind wir reingegangen werde noch
mal ganz kurz eben meine steine nehmen
und hier auch alles ein bisschen zu
bauen so dass wir uns auch hier nicht
runterfallen oder verletzten
[Musik]
ich habe wieder irgendwo im silberfisch
oder antrieb gehört
ich weiß aber gerade nicht wo
[Musik]
wir haben hier auf jeden fall noch
überall räume wir haben eine leiter die
nach oben geht keine ahnung was uns da
erwartet und wir haben noch nie vorne
die räume hier geht es noch weiter dass
noch eine tür hier ist noch eine tür
hier vorne geht der gang noch weiter in
stronghold ist wirklich riesig man hat
bibliothek noten sind ändern wir haben
hier eine menge monster und noch eine
menge er hat zu meiner lieben freunde
von daher würde ich an der stelle der
heutigen episode minecraft und lukas
auch beenden wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lass gerne einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da abonniert main kanal
und klickt auf die glocke wenn ihr neue
videos nicht verpassen wollte tipps habt
für die nächste episode minecraft mit
luca der wir uns dass rom heute weiter
anschauen werden dann schreibt jetzt
unten in die kommentare oder in die
gänge noch irgendwelche ideen vorschläge
oder irgendwelche anregungen wie die
letzten folgen dieses projekts dieser
staffel 1 von minecraft mit luca habt
schreibt auch gerne in die kommentare
wir sehen uns im nächsten video wieder
wenn wir das frommhold weiter entdecken